lassoo two's capital Masaru woke on
saturday to soldiers on the streets in a
televised address Prime Minister Tom to
Bonnie said they'd been deployed to
restore order he's declared a state of
emergency on Friday a court ruled
against her Bonnie's plans to suspend
Parliament where he was due to face a
vote of no-confidence this as Lesotho
nears the end of a national lockdown
because of the corona virus but police
chiefs say the army was deployed to
intimidate them they've accused Tapani
of being involved in the 2017 murder of
his second wife develop his current wife
has already been charged with murder
Deputy Police Commissioner Paseka
Marchetti speaks to us by a mobile phone
video he says he's gone into hiding but
the government says the men was simply
called in for questioning
Tapani says as a sitting Prime Minister
he can't be charged with murder he's
taken the matter to the Constitutional
Court which is yet to hear the case
Tapani had previously tried to fire the
police chief leading the murder
investigation but the courts prevented
it this is not the first time that the
police and army have been pitted against
each other as political tensions
increase in 2014 confrontations between
soldiers and the police left one police
officer dead and now as tensions ramped
up the South African government is
sending a special envoy to its neighbor
to mediate in the latest crisis
lesotho has a long history of Coos and
military involvement in it's often
fragile politics while Tapani has
promised to retire in July he continues
to face a position within and outside of
his own ruling pursue to national
convention the army has now withdrawn
but tension and uncertainty remain in
the tiny southern African kingdom femida
mela al jazeera